6 24 on your friday morning hey we're
talking the talk we're walking the walk
up at the 95 and the northern 215
beltway come on along
we're going centennial
bowling so instead of all the
yammering that i do every week about
this massive project how about you want
to see what it's going to look like when
it's done
three years from now it's very visually
stunning
sam lytle from the 3d rendering company
civil effects
isn't kidding like it's one thing for me
to keep saying that oso blanca is going
to run
under the 215. it's something else all
together
to see it as it's going to look
same goes for the extension of sky point
under
the flyover from west 215 to the south
95
but over the beltway on the east side of
the 95.
you can not only see the project's
growth from nothing
to flashing colors showing the different
phases along the way
and the centennial bowl is not all about
cars
when they say multi-use trail across the
95 they're not kidding
walkers joggers and bicyclists gonna
find
a lot to explore and you can review the
online version of this and all our
centennial bull stories with a link to
that very cool animation at
eightnewsnow.com when you click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and
please put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8
8 news now dot com